now you'll need this I can't take stop
and don't make my mistake if you see one
of those things uniform or not you do
not hesitate you take it out or you run
got it yes sir so that's now I know the
biggest change compared to the original
will naturally be the camera perspective
changing too over the shoulder behind
view but we've kept the gameplay style
as really classic survival horror
exploration Metroidvania style
backtracking and taking that as a basis
using the re engine which we deadly with
Resident Evil 7 to allow for updated
photorealistic
reimagined visuals but still presenting
the original gameplay experience this is
the kind of two aspects we've merged
together on the project so it should be
something that can appeal to modern
cameras from a technical perspective
while still bringing the classic
Resident Evil experience it was
difficult to reframe the action this way
what one thing we can do in
over-the-shoulder perspective which we
couldn't do with the original fixed
camera is bring an intense up-close
claustrophobic feeling to the encounters
especially when your fears a'm be it's
grabbing you and biting you you it's
right up in your face in the
over-the-shoulder camera in a way that
it isn't with the more zoomed out fixed
camera angles and that's something that
I think we can bring to the mix to kind
of make up for some of the things you
can't do anymore in terms of fixed
camera angle tricks and I think that
we're confident either way the gameplay
of this game is so good that it works in
either perspective style so just because
you change the perspective doesn't mean
that the game itself and the experience
is going to be completely you no longer
like the original we're expected
respecting the original game and the
nostalgia people have for it whilst
bringing in your experience it's been a
balance of having the freedom brought by
the new perspective and having the
difficulty you expect from a survival
horror experience
for example we mentioned where the
zombies are up close attacking you the
camera dynamically shifts to almost the
first-person view it's so close and in
addition the level design is something
we can use to really balance things out
so even though you've got more freedom
and aiming in 3d space
with over the over-the-shoulder
perspective the level designs are much
more 360-degree and in the previous game
so some creatures can attack you from
practically any angle and you're having
to look upon and shoot them that way and
that's very different from the more
straight on approach that you had with
the stop and shoot style of Resident
Evil 2 so I think that there's a lot of
bouncing to be done but we've really
achieved a great balance to make a
sensational experience a mosquito so
erotic into mono yoga in Dickens and I
cannot live in your ma Thomas
[Music]
so isn't it a normal day you will
definitely need to play both the Leon
and Clara campaigns to get the full
story in the game they're obviously set
in the same pace recurring city and the
same overall story is happening and the
gameplays got commonalities between them
but for example Leon is his you know
rookie cop who's just shown up at
Raccoon City he's really pushing to
investigate the truth behind this
incident and figure out what's going on
Clara's got different priorities she you
know she's come here looking for her
brother and then she meets this young
girl who needs protecting and she
decides she has to take care of her and
that's the driving force behind her
story so they both start off from
slightly different places and follow the
story in different ways and you I think
it's important for players to see both
sides of that to really get the full
Resident Evil 2 story Clara stole 100%
based on her the original character from
Resident Evil 2 as you mentioned the
visuals have been updated a bit bit but
more believable and grounded but the two
directors on the game are both huge fans
of Clara and they didn't want to just
reboot her character in this she's still
the same tear you know and love it's
just that she just looks a bit more
believable in the setting
[Music]
what's wrong we have built on the base
of the original game story being
reimagined and added new things like
areas who couldn't access before the
original game bringing new depth to the
existing characters or having different
characters in different combinations who
hadn't met before to bring new depth to
the story so it's a combination of both
things enough and I think that people
will be able to enjoy experiencing the
original story and then finding out what
kind of new accents and aspects we could
bring to it yeah we're not talking about
newness in terms of just unrelated
things to the main storyline is still
Leon and Claire's story and the new part
we've introduced are based in that
context rather than just being something
completely new for the sake of it not
tying in to the original game storyline
[Music]